thank you
I'm just going to read the emergency
evacuation announcement there are no
planned fire drills so if the alarm goes
off please leave the building in an
orderly fashion through the nearest fire
exit please either use the fire exit
through the main doors of the hall or
the fire exit to the saw room adjacent
to the stage
the fire assembly point is at the island
in front of the main entrance to the
building
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off mobiles or turn them
to silent
please note that the toilet and hand
washing facilities are in the foyer area
now please be outstanding members to
receive the chairman Reverend Nick Rowan
and the chief executive
foreign
[Music]
good evening members
members uh can I call upon Reverend Nick
Rowan for the Press
a verse from this evening's uh reading
from John's gospel Jesus washing his
disciples feet
Jesus said you call me teacher and Lord
and rightly so for that is what I am
now that I your lord and teacher have
washed your feet you also should wash
one another's feet
I have set you an example that you
should do as I have done for you
father God As We Gather this evening on
the day of the appointment of a new
prime minister a new government we pray
you would strengthen Grant wisdom and
give a heart of service to all who take
on these new roles
with the background of financial
uncertainty cost of living challenges
and war in Ukraine we pray for peace of
mind and the well-being for all citizens
of this District
and almighty God from whom comes every
good and perfect gift we pray that this
meeting will be conducted in a spirit of
justice and Truth wisdom and charity
we pray that mindful of their
responsibility and the needs of those
they serve each counselor and officer
may use their influence in this meeting
to promote the well-being of our
community
help them to seek the way of love and
peace and seek above all else to serve
others in the name of the Father the Son
and the Holy Spirit
amen
thank you Nick you are of course welcome
to stay but I do understand if you need
to disappear please please feel free to
do thank you members please be seated
[Music]
foreign
just before we start a couple of things
I'd like to just mention
members were also joined
this evening by Emily Ewell
and Steve Summers our strategic
directors
and Dan Goodman
our strategic strategic planner
over here somewhere on the top table I
think
foreign
members of the public
whilst you're a course entitled to to
film and take photographs during this
meeting
can I emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption
to the meeting and only be done from the
designated area in public seating
can I there can I please therefore ask
you to raise your hand clearly if you
wish to film and take photographs
thank you very much
members
just a few points to remind you
when I invite you to speak please wait
until the microphone is in front of you
before speaking as as the microphones
are needed for the hearing Loop
and for the audio recording the
can also mention to members that when
you stand and you hold the papers make
sure you're not covering the microphone
it does block sound
these are all switched on and ready for
you to speak so you do not need to
adjust them
make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of you before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
and I ask when I uh I will ask for a
show of hands
for
then against
recommendations and then for abstentions
given the size of this room and the
number of us present
can I please ask but you put your hand
up clearly
like you used to at school
high in the air
so that you can be easily seen
and leave it up until I ask you to lower
it
the normal rules of debate apply
no members should speak for longer than
five minutes
and can I please ask you not to repeat
anything previously said
all those indicating to speak will be
given an opportunity to speak once
item one apologies I have two
councilor Wilkinson and councilor Hoy
are there any others
thank you
a general item two minutes of the
meeting held on the 26th of July 2022
members
are you happy for me to sign the minutes
of the meeting held on the 26th of July
is that agreed members
foreign
Declarations of Interest
are there any
Declarations of Interest
can I remind members if something comes
up during the course of the meeting
please indicate clearly and we will
record your declaration at that point
foreign
announcements from the chairman leader
and head of pay services
members I'd like you if you would just
to bear with me for a few minutes
because I have a couple of things I'd
like to to mention
since our last meeting in July so much
has happened and changed and this is
momentous
time for the country
since we last met
we've had three prime ministers
four chancellors
and maybe another one to come
and so many changes to the cabinet I've
lost track
and who knows what the next few months
will bring
however
the very sad loss of our sovereign
Queen Elizabeth II
and a new King King Charles III is
uppermost in our minds
I feel honored and privileged
to read out to have read out the
proclamation for our new king
in the Roxford Market Square
and to attend the memorial service for
Queen Elizabeth and Saint Andrews
Roxford
along with many members visiting mayors
I for one
we're still trying to get the words
right for the national anthem
as I'm sure you know
putting together everything to enact
operation London was not an easy task
and has also done a very short notice
I would like to say a few words to those
who went above and beyond the Call of
Duty in organizing everything
Holly
Sonia
Veronica
all worked on the Civic side things
making the arrangements
Anna dealt with the comms
Jim for sending setting up the road
closure
Valerie for doing all the printing
and of course Colin our Civic chauffeur
and support officer who was responsible
for making sure that I was in the right
place at the right time
indeed one day we were actually attended
four church services throughout the
whole of South Essex
it all started when Holly contacted me
on the day that news started to come out
and I was sitting in my office at home
thinking oh I'm right up to date with
all my emails I'm gonna have a quiet
weekend
that's my first mistake
the officers worked behind the scenes
getting everything organized
but what you may not know is how long
and how much work it takes
I know how much time the team had to
spend putting
putting it in and worse
I'm sorry
I know how much time the team had to put
in and some were starting as early as 6
30 in the morning
and still answering emails at 10 o'clock
at night
I'd like to give them my personal thanks
and I'm assure you will agree with me
we have some outstanding officers
I would like to make a small
presentation to the officers
Holly who sadly can't be here this
evening
um she's not too well
and Sonia
who is here this evening
and the other officers
who have been unable to attend will have
a surprise tomorrow morning
I have asked if I'm extend
um I've asked councilor butcher if she
would be very kindly accept the
presentation on behalf of Holly and
she'll make sure she gets it delivered
tomorrow
sorry
[Applause]
sadly Colin is leaving us tomorrow
so I would like to thank him and I'm
sure the other past chairman will join
me in thanking him for making sure we
were always on time thank you
I feel Rochford has much to offer
and I have visited voluntary
organizations in business and businesses
to lend my support and raise awareness
for the wonderful facilities available
in our district
I was privileged to wave off
our ambitious colleagues from both
Brentwood and Rochford embarking on the
Three Peaks challenge at 24 Mile and
5240 ascent
I would ask you to join me in a
celebrating their impressive fund rating
for and formidable effort
of over 11
000 pounds
for cardiom or therapy
UK Parkinson's UK
whole field animal sanctuary and Saint
Francis hospice
along with my own chosen Charities
achievement through football and Trust
links
a lot of hard work and training went
into this grueling challenge
and I want to thank all of the staff
that supported
our Charities it is much appreciated
foreign
members thank you for indulging me
councilor Watson do you have any
announcements as leader
and can I ask
Mr Stevenson if you have any
announcements
no thank you chair thank you
members agenda item five
to note the minutes of the executive and
committee meetings held between the
period 14th of July to the 14th of
October 2022.
members are these noted
thank you
gender item six
Business from The Last council meeting
members does anyone have any questions
relating to the business from the last
council meeting held on the 26th of July
gender item seven report on urgent
decisions there are none
gender item 8 statement of community
involvement
2022 update
the report will be introduced by the
chairman of the planning policy
committee councilor Foster
can I remind my members to stand
apologies
I to make before you relates to an
update to the council's statement of
community involvement
it's Council Foster decided to interrupt
you can you move the microphone a little
closer it is difficult to hear you
is that better that's better
all right I'll start again I to make
before you relates to an update to the
council's statement of community
involvement
statement of community involvement is a
statutory document that sets out the
ways in which the council will engage
the public and other stakeholders in the
planning process including
planning policy development management
and development enforcement
there is a requirement in law to review
the statement of community community
involvement at least every five years
as a previous version was adopted by the
council in 2016
a review took place in 2021
that was at the planning policy
committee meeting of the 23rd of June
21.
the outcome of this review was the
subject of an eight-week consultation
exercise in Autumn 2021
the review and subsequent consultation
identifies a range of minor changes that
were required to keep the document
relevant and accurate
as well as some additional wording to
provide clarity
in some cases
details of the consultation process and
suggested changes are set out in the
feedback report at appendix a to this
item
the revised document was considered by
the planning policy committee on the
30th of August this year
where the committee resolved unanimously
to recommend the full Council that the
document be adopted
subject to further minor change
specifically to replace the word
informal with the word formal
I'll briefly explain
the changes as our way of introduction
the biggest area of changes relates to
Coronavirus and potential impact on
community engagement events in the
future
obviously covering any serious outbreaks
of Coronavirus
the report includes updates and methods
of communication and methods of
providing feedback
for example updating email addresses
Rochford Council email addresses were
out of date
removing faxes as an option of
communication
removing Twitter as an option of
communication
and removing Rochester District matters
as the key communication route or
engagement in the
in the community involvement doesn't
mean that can't be used as well if
there's a future decision
but it removes as a major method so that
was replaced with online news
in the older version of the statement it
refers to plans being available to view
Australian Rochford Rayleigh is now
removed as an option from the report
there are some corrections to grammar
there are some updates in engagement
opportunities reflecting government
regulations and they are 18 19 22 23 24
25 and 26 all mentioned in the report
on how to engage with in relation to
local plan development and finally there
are some changes to pre-application
rules which are on page 8.48
so that's a brief summary of some of the
changes as I said it was accepted
unanimously at the planning policy
committee meeting on the 30th of August
thank you
council Mrs Belton
[Music]
thank you chair
um I just have one point to make on page
8.48 paragraph 3.3 in regards to
pre-application
um at the moment it says pre-application
device is available for all types of
developments excluding householder
applications and applications for small
scale developments
I see this as a false economy removing
that service to our residents and it
will enable a sleeker process throughout
if they can ask the questions up front
and I would like to propose a small
amendment that we change the word
excluding to including and so that we
can offer a good customer service to our
residents
okay do you have a second of for that
proposition
okay Council wall chairman I would
definitely like to second that I think
we do need to improve our services and I
would like that looked into thank you
okay members we obviously now just
debating this amendment
um I've got councilor Mrs Mason wishes
to speak
[Music]
thank you I'm pleased that councilor
Belton pointed that out because I was
also going to raise it I know that we
have been unfortunately excluding our
Workshop District Council I should say
has been unfortunately excluding
residents from pre-application service
and this is wrong yet major developments
developers are able to have access to
the service so I certainly support the
amendment
but I would like to ask for further
clarification
probably less important now that we're
including I take it um we're including
not just
um householder but also small scale
developments so that inclusive activity
is quite correct we should be doing that
and we should have been doing it all
along but the question I was going to
ask
which is probably academic now was how
did we Define major but if we're
including all developments I don't think
I need to ask the officer to explain
that thank you and I certainly support
the motion
thank you
okay any other members to speak on this
okay council Mrs Belton would you just
like to repeat your proposal
[Music]
thank you chair
um page 8.48 paragraph 3.3 changed the
word excluding to including
members can I have a show of hands on
that everybody
it's four
members that thank you that is unanimous
that now becomes part of the substantive
motion
members is anybody wish to speak on the
on the motion on the
presentation
with no indications
okay
members there's two items on this paper
item one that the count the contents of
the statement of community involvement
feedback report and appendix a be noted
is that noted members
the statement of community involvement
at appendix B be adopted
members I need to show hands on this
those in favor
okay thank you members those against
and extensions
foreign
members that is 36 4 and 1 abstention
foreign
I thought that was death became part of
the substantive motion
okay right I'll let you raise that out
if you would okay members we do need to
take a third mode
um legal officer will explain thank you
chair
um as members have
voted there is now a new third
recommendation that recommendation is
that in paragraph 3.3 in appendix B the
word is to change the word from
excluding to including so the the new
sentence will read pre-application
advice is available for all types of
develop including householder
applications and applications for small
scale development developments such as
one house thank
members you've heard that does anybody
wish to speak to it
okay no no you can't nail anyone
um those in favor
members that's unanimous
okay
okay members moving on
agenda item nine report of of the leader
on the work of the executive
is that noted members
okay members
agenda item 10
public questions and member questions on
notice
members we have no public questions but
there are a number of member questions
or notice
which we will go through in turn
Council and Mrs Gooding can I invite you
to read out your question
to the portfolio holder for housing
assets and Leisure
please
good evening chairman
I've often approached my residents
and disability groups regarding the
facilities and the equipment at Clements
Hall Leisure Center
in particular the swimming pool and wet
side facilities which are in need of
upgrading to enable wheelchair users
some paralyzed from the neck down to
self-transfer from their electric
wheelchairs to wet chairs hoists as the
current equipment does not enable easy
access for a marginalized group of our
residents and they cannot even spectate
as the toilet facilities are also
Limited
my question is to the leader please can
the leader outline any recent or planned
Investments made by Fusion at Clements
Hall especially any facilities for
disabled users thank you
thank you council Mrs Gooding
councilor Webb would you please respond
to that question
[Music]
thank you chairman
can you hear me now thank you
is that better thanks
so chairman during the pandemic the
council supported its Leisure provider
to protect local jobs and to secure
future investment in our Leisure
facilities
the council was forward-thinking
recognizing that once we emerged from
the pandemic access to high quality
local Leisure facilities would be even
more vital to support the physical and
mental well-being of our residents I
personally did not want to see our
Leisure facilities remain shut and I'm
pleased that as a council we were able
to open them again
chairman I'm pleased to confirm that
Fusion lifestyle earlier this year
invested in new state-of-the-art gym
equipment spin bikes a sauna and a new
studio floor at Clements Hall Leisure
Center having used this equipment myself
I'm pleased to say that it Rivals
anything that the more expensive private
sector competitors can offer
additional investment is also made by
Fusion in the plant room to service the
swimming pools
the main sports hall floor is also due
to be replaced by the end of 2022 which
is a significant undertaking and will
benefit to all users of the main hall
additionally Fusion have invested in
radio Leisure Center which also has a
brand new gym
this gym equipment at both sites is
accessible as part of the strategy to
offer an inclusive Leisure service
this investment totals nearly 1 million
pounds approximately six hundred
thousand pounds at Clements Hall Leisure
Center and 300 000 at Riley Leisure
Center and is a clear demonstration of
the council's commitment to the health
and well-being of a residence
recent questions have been asked by
dementia care to consider implementing
at Clements Hall and O'Reilly Leisure
Center signage for dementia clients to
make a positive impact when visiting the
swimming pool area and the center is
also has also been asked to look at the
color of the flooring I'm pleased to say
that Fusion have responded positively to
this and that they will be looking to
get some new signage up immediately
to meet this local need
in terms of The Wider question councilor
Michael High has also raised this with
me and brought the work of changing
places to my attention
we will be looking at how best to adapt
adapt the Wet Side changing rooms to
accommodate users with limited Mobility
however this will require significant
investment and is more likely to be
achieved when we go out to the market to
review the Leisure contracts and asking
providers whoever they may be
to make substantial investment in our
Leisure centers as part of their
proposals as how to they would possibly
redesign the Leisure website changing
areas to incorporate those with limited
Mobility
thank you chairman
thank you councilor Webb Castle Mrs
Gooding do you have a supplementary
question no thank you chairman
thank you
Council Norman
can you please read out your question to
the leader
thank you chairman
quite simple to the leader please where
are we I welcome the fact that Mill Hall
in Raleigh has reopened but can the
leader give give please give an insight
into his vision and also reassurance on
the sustain sustainability for this
important Community facility
thank you Council Newman councilor
Wootton would you please respond to the
question
for your question and I'm pleased to be
able to respond
until recently The Mill Hall was part of
the council's asset delivery program
the commercial case for the ADP
continues to be strong but with the Mill
Hall I accept that there was very strong
Community resistance to the council's
proposals and any plans to redevelop The
Wider site will not now happen
because of its Community value it was
appropriate to separate this building
from the ADP and give a focus on how it
can operate cost effectively
structurally I'm assured that this
building is sound which is good news for
all of us sitting in here tonight that
said the Mill Hall needs substantial
capital investment and the revenue costs
of maintaining these premises are
considerable
but councilor Lawman like you I am
delighted that the Mill Hall has
reopened and I would like to take this
opportunity to thank the assets team for
all the hard work that they have done to
make this happen
it is pleasing that there has been early
interest in hiring space both during the
week and at weekends
the ongoing operation of this building
will be a commercial challenge but I am
personally determined and committed to
do my best to make it succeed
as for the vision we are in the midst of
reviewing the expressions of Interest
which recently came forward to use all
or parts of the premises for a broad
range of events and Ledger activities
discussions are ongoing and it is too
early to give an outcome
as for other possible uses I would like
to see it operated as a multi-use truly
community building where we have a
Rochford District Council reception area
for the public to visit as well as some
offices and meeting rooms perhaps a
cafeteria citizens advice working here
Essex Police business facilities NHS
uses
etc
etc
particularly I would like to see us
explore opportunities to showcase the
wonderful tapestry which is current in
the foyer and promote the rich Heritage
of the rainy and Rochford district and
engage with Essex County Council to
explore the possibilities for adult
education
any other ideas would be very gratefully
received
as for sustainability chairman where
that is concerned the phrase use it or
lose it comes to mind thank you chairman
thank you thank you councilor Woodard
Council Lawman do you have a
supplementary question
I have not chairman I'm very happy with
the reply thank you
councilor Mrs Shaw can you please read
out your question to the leader
can you move the microphone a little
closer please I'm sorry
finances in thorough Council can the
leader please provide reassurance that
there is a financial resilience within
Rochford District Council thank you
thank you council Mrs Shaw Council
Wootton would you please respond
thank you chairman thank you for your
question councilor Mrs Shaw
members will be well aware of the recent
media reports concerning thorough
council's finances
and whilst it is not my position to
comment on these specifically I would
like to provide reassurance to members
on the financial resilience of Rochford
District Council and the steps that
myself and the executive are taking to
ensure this continues into the future
firstly I want to make it quite clear
the excellent relationship between
members of this Administration and
officers within Rochford District
Council which is totally open
transparent and tested through scrutiny
and evidenced by long-standing
reputation and outcomes of doing the
best for residents and businesses within
our community
members should note that Rochford
District Council has an excellent track
record of delivering sound financial
management over the past few years
as an authority we have maintained a
clean external audit opinion on the
quality of our financial statements as
well as a positive opinion on the value
for money services that we deliver as an
authority
we have agreed a balanced budget each
February and contained our spending
within the budget year on year without
relying on any external borrowing and
the consequence that brings with ongoing
interest costs
neither do we lend us an authority thus
avoiding the consequences of risk
through possible default
unlike some councils rather than embark
on potentially risky investment schemes
we continue to implement innovative ways
of delivering better outcomes for our
residents through initiatives such as
our one-team partnership with Brentwood
our connected digital program improving
productivity through effective Process
Management managing our assets by
disposing of buildings
which are Surplus to our needs or no
longer fit for purpose thus avoiding
unnecessary costs and how simpler
council tax support scheme
in common with all local authorities
Rochford Council will face a challenging
Financial Outlook over the coming year
and Beyond
to a large part this is caused by
factors outside of our Direct Control
notably The Wider economic situation and
high levels of inflation that we Face
currently
we are not immune to those factors
whilst we hold sufficient reserves to
enable us to weather any sort term
shocks and also continue to invest in
our communities it is nevertheless our
responsibility as a council to face up
to these Financial challenges to ensure
we can balance our books going forward
the executive continues to con to
consider all possible options for
Service delivery as we work on our
medium-term financial strategy and this
will involve making some tough choices
but rest assured we will not take any
decisions without a full consideration
of any risks involved
however ultimately the greater risk is
that if we take no action now we will
not be able to ensure the financial
resilience of the council in future so
it is incumbent on us all especially
this conservative Administration to
responsibly engage with this Challenge
proactively and that colleagues is what
and that colleagues is what we are
committed to do thank you chairman
thank you Council Wilson
Council Mr Shaw do you have a
supplementary question
councilor Mrs Carter can you please read
out your question to the leader
yeah can the leader please clarify the
arrangements in place for Rochford
District Council to work with the NHS to
accommodate the NHS breast screening
unit within the district please
thank you councilor Mrs Carter councilor
Wootton would you please respond
thank you chairman
uh thank you council Mrs Carter for your
question and before I answer it can I
take this opportunity to formally
welcome you to the conservative group in
making your decision to walk the floor
you said that it is a pleasure to be
part of a well-organized party and part
of a group that conducts themselves in a
professional and courteous manner he
also said that they are have the best
vision for the people in our community a
very warm welcome to you turning now to
the answer to your question chairman I
met with colleagues in the NHS to
reaffirm the council's commitment to
supporting the NHS breast screening
program in the district we fully support
the NHS breast screening units efforts
to dinner very comprehensive screening
program across the district in the fight
against breast cancer
Rochford District Council has been clear
in its offer to the NHS for the unit to
be placed on any Council owned site of
the nhs's choosing subject to the site
meeting the nhs's accessibility in the
electrical supply requirements free of
charge
currently the unit is in our South End
Road car park in Hockley offered free of
charge which has been in use by
residents since May of this year thank
you chairman
thank you councilor wooden council Mrs
Carter do you have a supplementary
question no thank you
foreign
can you please read out your question to
the leader
or stroke Deputy leader I would say
okay I'll address my um question too
the deputy leader as a I think the lead
has acquire can you just move a little
closer
is that bad sir that's better I'll
address my question to the deputy leader
as uh I'm sure the leaders answered
quite a lot of questions already and uh
could
could the deputy leader please tell us
how many full-time employees and
part-time employee vacancies they
currently are at Rochford District
Council
thank you councilor Newport
counselor Mrs Rowe can you please
respond
it's a new book for your question
currently
currently against budget forecast there
are 20 vacancies 17 full-time and three
part-time thank you chairman
Council Mr Newport do you have any
supplementary question yes of course
chairman thank you
um
in 2010
um the council published the customer
Charter which makes a number of aims two
of which are answering telephone calls
within 15 seconds and aiming to
acknowledge emails from residents within
one working day
judging from the complaints from
residents and from my own personal
experience and that of other minority
groups these aims are very rarely met in
our experience
will this failure be addressed by the
administration anytime soon by perhaps
recruiting more staff
council Mrs Rowe would you like to
respond
[Music]
thank you chairman we will refer this to
Jonathan Stevenson thank you
much as well
thank you chairman
um with regard to your question Council
Newport obviously the organization has
got total employees at the moment 156 I
know you're referring to 2010. obviously
no members of Staff would not want to
answer a call or answer an email but
obviously I've got a reduced Workforce
since 2010 you've raised a good point
around the customer Charter and I think
it's something that we should pick up
with regards to the one service review
looking at showing joint teams and
intentions looking to have more
resources across both councils overall
so very much on your point that
someone's definitely address that
customer Charter of 2010 and we'll have
a look at that could you hear me on
okay
let the work out
um to answer your question councilor
Newport with regard to the customer
Charter in 2010. obviously I wasn't
there now but obviously was an ambition
to answer calls in 15 seconds and I'm
sure it's still an ambition of officers
no one deliberately doesn't answer a
call or response to an email
um the resource in 2010 is very
different to what it is now we've got
currently 156 ftes within the
organization
um I haven't got the figure in front of
me in 2010 but I'm sure it was a lot
more than on that figure and with the
one team work we're looking to do we'll
look to review that customer Charter and
ensure that whatever customer charge we
have for our staff we can here to moving
forward
doesn't care
thank you
counselors cross can you please read out
your question to the portfolio holder
for housing assets and Leisure
thank you Mr chairman we acknowledge
that the recommissioning and six month
appraisal of the potential for the Mill
Hall arts and events center is underway
and some aesthetic improvements have
been completed will the portfolio holder
for housing assets and Leisure
tell the council the outline plans for
the next phase of the refurbishment in
particular the scoping the assessment
and the costings thank you
councilor Webb would you like to respond
Council of course for your question
chairman I'm delighted to see the
improvements completed recently to the
Mill Hall
members will have noted the new carpet
decorations the reception area and main
hall
as well as the external render to the
front of the building also being
redecorated
the main hall floor has been sanded and
Polished we have also installed a
hearing Loop which I'm told is working
extremely well
I would also encourage members to either
watch a district Heritage tapestry in
the reception area I had a look at it
earlier and it's an exceptional piece of
work
I'm delighted to see many groups that
use the hall before the pandemic are now
returning and they're also new groups
are booking the facility
I would like to thank Matt and the
Leisure team and asset team for the
tireless work to reopen the building I'm
sure you'll agree that they have done a
fantastic job in a very short space of
time
in July I reported the executive set out
that the council would enter into a
community expression of Interest process
seeking expressions of interest from
from potential Community Partners
the process has been well received by
the community and I was pleased to meet
with many groups and individuals as part
of the process
a further report will come back before
the executive in December setting out
the outcome of this process and the
investment this Council will make to the
building to support its long-term
sustainability thank you chairman
that's crossed you have a supplementary
question
uh I do thank you Mr chairman
um I didn't hear Too Much in the way of
budget allocation there but um in May
2021 uh the then strategic director of
Rochford District Council or managing
director of Rochford District district
council indicated that the refurbishment
costs of Mill Hall were likely to be in
the region of up to three and a half
million pounds now that was well over a
year ago building costs of increased
substantially since then with inflation
Etc labor costs Etc
so what I'd like to know is is there
sufficient
in the budget for the count from the
council to allow for such refurbishments
to take place thank you
Castle web would you like to respond
thank you chairman as I said the report
will be coming to the executive in
December where we will outline the
proposed refurbishment that will take
place within this building
as you know we're undertaking an
expression of Interest process that is
going extremely well and until that is
completed we won't actually know who's
going to be coming into this building
and the requirements that they would
have for using it so if I could ask
Council across hope to wait till
December and I look forward to receiving
the full report which I'll then share
with you thank you
thank you thank you babe
counselor sharp can you please read out
your question to the portfolio holder
for strategic planning
thank you chair
I think we all appreciate that the new
local plan
presents the council just a little
closer please yep
sorry is that better that's better
I think we all appreciate that the new
local plan
presents the council with its biggest
challenge
I'm given to understand that it's now
four and a half years
since the previous concert consultation
issues and options
but the planning policy committee
meetings appear to be few and far
between
will the portfolio holder commit to
holding more regular brief count all
councilor briefings on the progress of
the local plan
foreign
would you please respond
chairman thank you
I would like to thank councilor sharp
for his question
as he has alluded to the fact that the
local plan will be this council's
biggest challenge but it will also be
this council's biggest opportunity for
managed infrastructural growth and
investment
I would like to correct councilor sharp
regarding the latest consultation stage
on the council's new local plan has not
been four and a half years ago but
rather one year ago
this stage was called the spatials
options stage
feedback from which has and will
continue to be reported into the
planning policy committee
on the subject of member briefings on
the local plan these have been provided
in a range of settings since this
consultation ended including at the
planning policy committee together with
member training sessions I would
particularly like to draw members
attention to the dedicated all member
briefing sessions held on the 23rd of
June
progress on the local plan will continue
to be monitored through the planning
policy committee and further member
briefings will be held including
dedicated sessions such as that which
took place on the 23rd of June
as and when there are key outcomes to
report or where the council is
approaching an important decision-making
stage a dedicated all member briefing
session will be initiated thank you
thank you Council Ward
Castle sharp do you have a supplementary
question I don't have a supplementary
question but I'd like to thank councilor
um for his clarification and correction
and look forward to those further meet
all Council of meetings thank you thank
you Council shop thank you Sean
Castle constable
can I please can you please read out
your question to the portfolio holder
for the environment
thank you Mr chairman I was pleased to
hear that the council successfully
Closer Closer still is that better
thank you Mr chairman I was pleased to
hear that the council successfully
prosecuted an individual for a dark
smoke offense recently with a fine hire
than any penalty for an offense of this
kind before
now that the litter strategy has been
agreed and a contract with Norse is
underway can we expect Rochford District
Council to take the same strong approach
to fly tippers in the area
thank you Council constable
counselor
Mrs Perry would you like to respond
thank you chairman uh thank you
councilor Constable the short answer is
yes
undertaking enforcement on fly tipping
and knittering is one of the key pillars
of the new latest strategy
and to demonstrate that we will not
tolerate this in any way across the
district
however as a council we will always
prosecute fly tippers where it is
proportional and practical to do so and
we have previously prosecuted an
individual for persistent fly tipping
with the successful prosecution finding
him guilty and he received a penalty of
200 hours of unpaid work through a
12-month community order
more commonly a fixed penalty notice is
issued and so far we have issued six to
date in 2022
at the moment an early payment of these
notices results in the fire being
reduced by a half to 200 pounds
I am proposing that this Council sets a
fine for fly tipping at the maximum
figure of three of four hundred pounds
that legislation will allow but without
any reduction for early payment to send
a clear message that this council is tap
on fly tipping thank you chairman
thank you Council sparing Cass constable
do you have a supplementary question
I'm very pleased to hear that we are
going to take a strong approach and I'd
like to see those figures of
prosecutions increase in the future
thank you
members that is the end of the questions
we'll move now on to agenda item 11.
motions or notice
members we have two motions on notice
which will be taken in turn
the first is proposed by councilor Mr
Newport and secretive by councilor
Stanley
councilman's Newport would you like to
introduce your motor motion on notice
thank you chairman for the opportunity
to bring this motion forward some
members may remember this motion as we
previously did bring It Forward
myself and the late Craig canal so um
it's an important motion to us
as a group
we know that the tradition of fireworks
tonight brings great joy for many of our
residents but equally for many
in what has become an extended fireworks
period it brings Stress and Anxiety
military veterans residents with autism
pets animals and those fleeing conflicts
from war-torn countries are often
affected psychologically and
unfortunately in some cases physically
the motion that we propose to council
tonight does not seek to be a kill Joy
approach but to support the whole
Community by taking positive actions to
ensure that alternatives are made
available for residents such as that of
Silent fireworks and the details of
public displays that will give residents
prior notice of when large displays are
to be held
it will give residents that enjoy
fireworks an opportunity to make those
informed choices and those that do not
wish to participate in this tradition a
chance to take precautions to mitigate
the risks
members I urge you to support this
motion tonight to support making our
community safer fairer and a better
place for all that live here and if I
may chairman just um make one fine one
small change to the wording of the
motion at 11.2
um if I could just change the wording
from ensure all to encourage all public
firework displays it's just a very small
change as a
a colleague helpfully
um pointed that out to me earlier thank
you chairman
councilor Stanley can you confirm your
second in
the motion and the amendment
so I can't see from you
yes thank you chairman
councilman Williams
thank you chairman
um are we speaking to the amendment
first
remember
guys chairman are we speaking to your
Amendment first you have to repeat the
amendment first okay can I come in after
the amendment's been discussed
members do as anybody wish to speak on
the amendment
Council award
thank you
I find the change
encouraging he said a small change
that's a massive change
legally massive change to encourage as
opposed to ensure and i would support
that totally thank you
any others
Newport would you just like to repeat
your Amendment and then we'll put it to
vote
thank you chairman yes 11.2 just like to
change the word in from ensure or to
encourage all public firework displays
thank you
members that commandment is before you
those in favor
thank you members
that's unanimous
members that now becomes part of the
strength of motion
councilor Williams do you wish to speak
on that
yes thank you chairman
as long as you're working yeah I think
it's working I'd like to Williams it may
be easy if you hold the mic up
it's asking
yeah thank you chairman
um I'd like to to thank the councilors
councilor new Paul and Stanley thank you
very much members Rochester District
Council is usually provided with a list
by Essex County Council of licensed
firework sellers in the area
these are regulated by Essex County
Council not Rochford District Council
locally
we are unable to enforce a requirement
on event organizers to advertise
firework events when it is on private
land we can only influence events that
are held on Council land
officers ensure that these are
advertised on on the Rochford Council
website to make local residents aware of
such events
some event organizers do complete event
management plans for scrutiny by their
safety Advisory Group known as sags
therefore officers can ensure those are
also advertised but there will be some
events such as schools
Etc that the council will not be aware
of the event
in relation to the rspca campaign
we can as a council support their
campaign and pledge to Lobby the
government but as they State primary
events are outside our control
I fully support the sentiments and have
sympathy with this motion but see little
point in formalizing a motion that its
actions we are already we are we are
unable to enforce or already do so
I therefore Pro propose that its
contents be amended to be noted and that
government be lobbied regarding the
points raised thank you chairman
Council Williams do you have a secondary
for that Amendment
yes for sure I think your hands are
first
I'll second it thank you
members will now take the amendment
does anybody wish to speak councilor
Newport
thank you chairman um
I think the cabinet member missed
speaking to the amendment which
clearly stated that we would be
encouraging rather than
ensuring which does get does put a
little bit of different perspective on
the motion so it's it isn't I understand
what the portfolio holder is saying that
we don't we cannot legally obligate
anyone to
advertise the event but this motion
seeks to encourage our residents and
organizers
of um big events to notify the council
so I don't feel that the portfolio
holder was actually speaking to the
amendment and perhaps rather speaking to
the original motion
thank you chairman
Council Williams thank you chairman
um thank you councilman I believe that
this was only to be noted anyway but yes
I fully fully agree with that thank you
any other members wish to speak
foreign
thank you chairman
um
just like to ask if this if that
prop motion should be noted and
no no vote should be put on that as it
is what's already been said by councilor
no no Port thank you
we need to take the amendment that
councilor Williams has suggested Castle
Williams would you like to please repeat
your Amendment
thank you chairman um
ability covered there
yes
okay
okay councilor Williams sorry to
interrupt you then
um can you please re-illiterate your
Amendment or therefore yeah thank you
chairman I therefore propose that its
contents be amended to be noted and that
government be lobbied regarding the
points raised
thank you
thank you Council Williams
members I need to show hands on that
could I please have a show of those in
favor
[Music]
okay
thank you members those against
it okay thank you members any
abstentions
hey members
that's 22 4.
14 against
and one abstention
okay members that now becomes the
Castle Mr Newport
thank you chair can I just have some
clarity as to what's just happened
because councilor Williams actually took
that back what he originally said and
now now we've just voted on it it's a
little bit confusing as to what's
happened
foreign
that was a motion that amendment was put
forward and was seconded and we had to
take a vote on that
okay
members the substantial amount motion
now just come becomes
to be noted
can I ask members is that Julie noted
thank you members
Castle Newport
could you record my name in the minutes
as a Gates that being noted thank you
certainly welcome
okay members the second motion
sorry members the second motion on
notice which has been proposed by
councilor Squires Mrs Squires Coleman
and seconded by councilor Williams
counselor Mrs Squires common could can
you please introduce your motion on
notice
I'd like to refer can you hold it just a
little closer yes sure I'd like to refer
you to the motion in front of you warm
spaces
as we are all aware there is a cost of
living crisis in the UK resulting in an
unprecedented pressures on residents
many of whom are already in poverty and
this winter despite the support given by
the government hundreds if not thousands
of Rochford residents will be forced to
make tough decisions about when and if
they can afford to heat their homes
Charities have warned that low-income
families and individuals are already
being forced to choose between falling
behind on bills going without Essentials
or taking on expensive debt
until his more is done by the government
it seems inevitable that proper and
proper the RDC will need to think about
doing more to help its residents warm
spaces are heated at safe spaces where
residents are invited to join a regular
inclusive community-run event they are
given the opportunity to get and stay
warm and to talk to each other over a
hot drink and maybe a snack
there might also be opportunities to
receive practical tips and advice on
saving energy costs and keeping safe and
warm at home
how to alleviate food and fuel poverty
warm spaces are not nor should ever be a
permanent solution to cost of living
pressures but under the current
circumstances and until the economic
Outlook improves or further measures are
put into place by government we should
be showing a commitment to help our
residents access the essential and basic
requirements of warmth to this end this
motion proposes that RDC will create a
directory of all like organizations
providing warm spaces for our residents
organizations that register are added to
the directory which we could be
advertised through RDC it is also
proposed that the council operates a
grant funding process setting aside a
fund of 5000 from the council's general
fund accounts which would award up to
500 pounds to successful applicants
in putting forward this motion I'd just
like to say a great how grateful I am to
councilor William Williams for a second
in this motion thank you
Council Williams I believe you're second
in this motion
yes thank you chairman
you may not speak on the motion yes
please don't thank you chairman
um
members
thank you councilor Mrs uh Squires
common for this
um it's always good to receive a motion
that positively affects our residents I
have no hesitation in second this motion
as the cost of living crisis begins its
grip on the county many of our residents
and businesses in Rochford will need to
adapt and in some cases make difficult
decisions
we are committed to deliver on our
commitment to support promote develop
and enable Rochford District voluntary
sector in providing effective services
that meet the needs of our residents and
businesses
this has never been so vital given the
challenges ahead
we are focused on working with our
partners locally county-wide and
nationally to make sure that the support
and guidance is readily available when
and where residents and businesses need
it
the council has launched a dedicated web
page to provide
information guidance and sign posting
for anyone needing advice on where to
get support
the council's response centers around
five
themes support with money and bills
support with food and Essentials support
with well-being go green and a GE
efficient support with work
an action plan has also been developed
to ensure that there is a whole system
approach to provide the much needed
support
for our staff residents and businesses
to be able to respond to the cost of
living issues they may face
warm spaces are winter warmth and
welcome spaces are being developed
across the county
and a mapping exercise is being
undertaken by Essex County Council they
have also just released their new
community winter warmth and welcome
spaces fund
they have allocated 100 000 pounds which
offers grants of up to 1 000 pounds so
organizations can create new spaces or
activities or extend their existing
Services the fund is open to all
Charities clubs or associations
Community interest companies
and towns and Parish councils
we are supporting this locally and have
worked with revs to identify
opportunities within our district which
is why I'm happy to Second the councilor
Squires
Coleman's motion to continue our efforts
and provide additional support for any
organizations wishing to create or
extend their existing service provision
as councilor Mrs Squires
Coleman's said the moment the motion
proposes that this Council operates a
similar grant funding process setting
aside a fund of 5 000 pounds
from the council's general fund account
which would award up to 500 pounds to
successful applicants so thank you
members thank you
Castle's Newport
[Music]
thank you chairman
I don't think we need uh reminding who's
caused this problem
um
and I really do hope that all those in
desperate need know how to use the
internet because it seems as if this
council's imagination extends to a
council web page
so it's quite disappointing the response
I feel personally
but however I do support the the
principle of uh
cancer
the council's motion
and I do think that we should be
offering as much help as is practically
possible
however I would like to propose an
amendment to the motion on page 11.3
and the amendment I would like to
make and I don't know if anyone wants to
take this down because it's quite a long
Amendment
following example of many other District
councils it's proposed by this motion
that the option of offering grants to
voluntary organizations registered
Charities unincorporated clubs
associations and small community groups
community in interest companies and
Parish and town councils to help with
costs is established by the council a
small Grant scheme will supplement any
potential funding from Essex County
Council
I feel that brings it in line with what
the Essex County Council are offering
and what groups to make the application
process less confusing for applicants
so that we get a wider
um
a
wider application
RDC will another
um change would be RDC will provide
grants in line with the guidance issued
by the ealc for the community and winter
warmth and welcome fund because that
spells out quite clearly what the fund
can be used for and can't be used for
and I think that
if that was adopted by this Council it
would make this a lot quicker process
thank you
Council Newport
do you have a copy of what you've just
proposed uh it's been a little difficult
for officers to write that down as
quickly as you spoke of spoke it do you
have a written copy of it a training
course on shorthand chairman yeah I'm
gonna have in the next two minutes I can
absolutely
um email it to officers if they so wish
councilman Newport if you could kindly
bring it up our officer will take a
photograph of it
of course
um Madame Vice chair
[Music]
I don't think of time members
[Music]
thank you
very much members
okay thank you councilman report
tell us about Mrs Mason
can I just wait uh for clarity if we're
speaking to an amendment or the
promotion
because I think we're in another
situation where the uh process seems to
be a little confused thank you
yes we will make sure that the whole
thing is repeated Council new Porter's
proposed councilor Mrs Belton
thank you I'm not sure if I'm alone but
I didn't understand half of what was
just put forward there and there was an
awful lot of information about rules
legislation a guidance that a lot of us
maybe haven't seen and possibly would
have been helpful to have that in
advance it's my understanding that the
councilors have done a lot of work on
this motion with the proposal and if
we're going to vote on anything I think
it's fair that we understand what we're
voting on thank you
um for clarity I think we actually need
to have a second off with you
motion that counts in Newports put
forward
I should like to second that gentlemen
thank you thank you
Council Foster you indicated
women
Council Billings coin we've been asking
I'd say Council Foster Mike a little
closer please I'd sort of reiterate
councilor belton's comments in the sense
that we've been asked to vote on ealc
guidance and I've got no idea what that
is
okay any other members wish to speak
yes Newport
[Music]
just for um Clarity for men some members
who maybe haven't read up on the winter
warmth and welcome spaces fund and the
motion does reference the
um Essex County Council and support
given and Essex County councilor
actually delegated to the ealc to
administer the fund that's available so
that's where the information would be
and it is in the motion about Essex
County Council
providing support
councilor Mrs Mason
[Music]
thank you chair I think I'm equally
confused by this amendment
um Council Belton I really don't know
um
what uh
why we're being asked this because it
seems to over complicate which is a very
simple a very straightforward and a very
hard worked with a lot of
assistance from both officers and
councilor John Mason but you know we we
have a motion that is put forward that I
think everyone understood I think we're
now in a state of confusion so I don't
know what to do to be honest thank you
does anybody else wish to speak on the
Amendments councilor wouldn't
thank you chairman I just want to
endorse exactly those points we seem to
be in a situation where we're confusing
unnecessarily the confused uh I'm
totally confused we've got uh proposals
in front of us on something that some of
us haven't read about and I'm really
quite disappointed because this is a
very good motion
um that we're proposing is being
proposed I applaud uh councilor Mrs
Squires Coleman for bringing it forward
and I also applaud Rochford District
residents for working with us as a group
to actually Bring It Forward the
sentiment Sentiments of it are extremely
clear and I'm delighted to support the 5
000 pounds I think uh judging by the
last motion we're in a danger of going
down a route of confusion and I really
would prefer us not to go down that
route chairman thank you
I could just take images
Council Newport we'll now take this to
the vote would you please just reiterate
your amended motion
to
um muddy the water if you like it was
merely that
the motion was very limited to voluntary
organizations what I have intended to do
was widen that to clubs and associations
and Community groups
so if you want me to read out the
amendment again I'm quite happy to do
that
yes if you could so and if you could
make it clear some members have got a
good understanding of what that is and
then we'll take the vote okay
so follow
unfortunately I can't get both of them
up on the same on the screen at the same
time but
so my amendment was following the
example of many other District councils
it is proposed by this motion that the
option of offering grants to voluntary
organizations
and then I've added in registered
Charities unincorporated clubs
associations and small community groups
Community interest companies and Parish
and town councils that's the part that's
been put in
to widen the groups that this fund is
available to to help with costs
to help with the cost is established by
the council
a small Grant scheme will supplement any
potential funding from Essex County
Council
then the other line is RDC will provide
grants in line with the guidance issued
by the ELC which is the guidance
provided by Essex County Council for the
community and winter warmth and welcome
fund to make the criteria quite clear
it's already set thank you Council
Newport
councilor Mrs Mason very quickly before
we put this to the vote I'll try to be
quick
I I think if counselor Newport had
limited his
um amendment to registered Charities
clubs Etc we would have understood it
but I think the rest of it is unhelpful
and so I won't be supporting the
amendment thank you
members we now put this to the vote
those in favor of the amendment please
signify
those against
thank you members any abstentions
okay
okay members that's nine four
twenty five against and three
abstentions that Amendment to the motion
is lost
counselor Mrs Squires Coleman we now
move back to the original motion
would you now please
summarize that motion which I believe
is on page 11.3 if you could just read
that out just to clarify some members
got full understanding thank you sorry
so the proposed motion is that RDC will
create a directory of all organizations
providing warm spaces for our residents
organizations that register are added to
this directory which could be advertised
through RDC it is also proposed that the
council operates a grant funding process
setting aside a fund of 5 000 pounds
from the council's general fund account
which would award up to 500 pounds to
successful applicants
thank you Council Williams just to
confirm you're still happy to second
that
okay members
we now put that to the vote those in
favor
foreign
any abstentions
okay members that's 36 4
now I'm against and one abstention
that motion is carried
members that concludes to me that the
business for this meeting
the meeting I close my watch says nine
o'clock
so thank you members thank you for your
time thank you
foreign
[Music]